[Musique] d'
accord,
c'est vraiment juste une étape importante même si nous
avons beaucoup de travail devant nous,
sachant que le vaccin sera
efficace, c'est une excellente nouvelle, mais nous
devons encore
terminer le processus réglementaire qui
implique de
terminer l'étude et de générer plus de
données  même quelques données de suivi et de sécurité
et ensuite, bien sûr, nous devons nous occuper de la
fabrication, nous espérons avoir environ 20
millions de doses de vaccin d'ici la fin
de cette année
et nous sommes impatients de fabriquer
environ 500 millions à un milliard de doses
l'année prochaine
mais ça va être une opération 24h/24 et 7j/7
ce ne sera pas moderna seul qui résoudra
ce problème ça va nécessiter beaucoup de
vaccins comme on le dit depuis un
moment
mais on espère pouvoir faire notre part
d'ici  vers l'avant et c'est une
étape vraiment importante dans ce voyage que
vous